so all of a sudden Gavin Newsom is  putting out some pretty interesting  campaign ads trolling Floridians by  running a Florida ad for his California  gubernatorial campaign saying to  Floridians hey you guys are stuck in an  authoritarian hellhole my words not his  come to California where we have more  freedom I urge all of you living in  Florida to join the fight or join us in  California where we still believe in  freedom freedom of speech freedom to  choose freedom from hate and the freedom  to love don't let them take your freedom  paid for by Newsome for California  Governor 2022. I don't find Gavin Newsom  to be the most Progressive I don't find  Gavin Newsom to be the most upstanding  morally but the polling suggests that  Gavin Newsom could be a very interesting  candidate in 2024 for the Democrats let  me know what you think in the comments